تحت عنوان شاء عمري لاول مره زوج يقيم
دعوا قضائيه ضد زوجته بالتعسف في استخدام
الحق في طلبها للخلع بالفعل زوج رفع دعوى
قضائيه يطالب فيها زوجته بالتعويض المدني
على خلفيه اتهامها بالتعصف استقدام الحق
في طلبها للخلع اقامت هي الدعوه الخلع بعد
كم سنه بعد ثلاثين عاما من الحياه الزوجيه
واستولت على ممتلكاته التي قضى عمره في
تحصيلها في الخارج لمده خمسه عشره سنه ثم
خلعته هذه دعوه تعد من الدعاوى المقامه
لاول مره في المحاكم المصريه بحسب ننسى
القانون المصري فان الخلع واقع بقضاء
القاضي ولا يحق للزوج الاعتراض عليه حكم
الخلق هو حكم نهائي لسينافي اصبح واقعا
يعيش الزوج من حين اعلانه استلام الحكم
المذكور لكن الزوج هنا استند في دعواه
القضائيه على القانون المدني وحكم سابق
لمحكمه النقد
[موسيقى]
الخلع بالنسبه للمراه اذا كان ثمه ضرر فهو
حق ولكن متى يعتبر استغلال للرجل والرجل
هنا يكون
المستغل او المستضعف طبعا هو في فرق بين
الخلع وفي فرق بين الطلاق فالطلاق هو ان
الزوج كره الحياه مع زوجته وهنا الامر
بيكون بايد الزوج نفسه انما بالنسبه للخلع
فهو من الزوجه هي اللي كرهت الحياه مع
زوجها وفي الحاله دي هي اللي بتطلب
الانفصال او انهاء العلاقه الزوجيه وفي
الحالتين في انهاء للعلاقه الزوجيه في
حاله الطلاق الزوج بيعطي للزوجه كل
مستحقاتها ومتفق وما اتفق عليه بينهم
وبيتم الطلاق بالتراضي انما في حاله الخلع
الزوجه هي اللي بتعطي بتعطي لزوجها
الصداقه اللي نقدمه لها واي هدايا قدمه
لها وعلشان ايه يتم الانفصال حقوقها
بالظبط كده في الحالتين دول بيكون انتهاء
تبرقه بالظبط كده فهنا بيكون انتهاء
للعلاقه الزوجيه المفروض في حل الحادثه
اللي احنا بنسمعها دلوقتي دي
لو كان في طمع او استغلال او حاجه زي كده
ما بيكونش بقى 30 سنه من الزواج لان انا
سامع ان حضرتك بتقول ان هو قعد 30 سنه
منها ان الموضوع هنا في الحلقه دي هو
موضوع كراهيه متراكمه على مدار سنين طويله
قوي وجه الوقت اللي هي ابتدت تنتقم منه في
سوره الخلق او في سوره الانتقام باخذ
الاموال وكل الحاجات دي اسمح لي شوي هلا
في حالات كتير وحالات طلاق بتصير بعد عقود
من الزواج وبكون يعني الهدف منها مش
الاستغلال
والطمع وما الى ذلك في ناس مضطره انها
ظروفها ما كانت تسمح لها للطلاق في اطفال
كانوا صغار استنوا على كبروا فبالتالي مش
بالضروره
من وراء الخلع في كل مره لانه على علمي
انه يعني عندما تطلب المراه الخلع
ستتخلى عن حقوقها فبالتالي يعني لما كان
للطمع في هذا الموضوع هي فقط تريد حريتها
بالضبط هو الخلع ليس في مجال للطمع
وبالضبط كده هي لما خدت الفلوس دي وخدت
الشقه والحاجات دي ليس طمع بقدر ما هو
انتقام المراه بطبيعتها طبيعتها اللي ربنا
خلقها عليها عطوفه وحنونه وجميله وطيبه
انما لما بيوصل لوقتي
وفي صبوره الزوجه حضرتك اكثر واحده حريصه
على استقرار البيت ده احنا قبلنا على كده
الانثى بالطلاق مباشره وتتاخر على بين ما
توصل اولادها لبر الامان على كل حال
لانها بتصبر مره واتنين وتلاته وسنه
واثنين وثلاثه ويحصل الانفجار مش هتاره
الزوج انه ما يسمحش بالانفجار ده يحصل
شطاره الزوج انه دائما يزود
يدوب المشاكل اولا باول